you got to look at it from my
perspective like before I had made those
comments they saying draymond's going to
therapy like what I'm supposed to think
they say somebody going to therapy I'm
hope he get better from that and hope he
learn from whatever he feel like he
needs to learn from going to therapy so
that's all I heard and I'm glad he's
back I'm glad he can move past that
Draymond is a incredible teammate he got
his times where he loses temper but
everybody has those times and I'm sure
they all Wonder all happy to have back
but I didn't mean no ill will by what I
said I know sometime some people look at
me as this malicious
snake passive aggressive like I I know
how people feel about me sometimes so
when I say I don't mean no harm by
nobody I don't mean to disrespect him or
his family if he felt that way I'm just
glad he's back on the court